just a few days ago we were watching a
television show
that was set in the early 1980s and one
of the characters was working away
at a desktop computer and it sparked
some some memories for me that i thought
i'd like to share in part because they
were you know pretty pleasant
memories and and you know they're kind
of cool and
and i think people could probably either
derive something from them
or relate to them and so this is really
about
something that my dad and i shared over
the course
of a winter going into spring when we
took
a computer class together and you know
the computers back then were these big
solid desktop models where the monitor
which was usually
green and black there wasn't any color
at that time
at least for most types of computers it
was
like one solid case and you know the
motherboard and all the other stuff was
inside of it
back then they they were just starting
to come out with
floppy disks but you know the ones that
we had actually used tape cassettes
for recording things you know like the
the old cassettes not the reel to reel
but the ones that you would pop into a
boom box and so they could kind of do
double duty for that
and when i was in elementary school and
i finished elementary school in 1980
there was it wasn't a secret room but
it was very hard to find you had to know
like where to go
and it had i think two or three
commodore computers in it and they were
these things you know the
screen was about this big and you had to
enter everything in with the loss you
had to type in your programs you could
record something and then you know
upload that into the computer
and i had a friend uh keith sakura
who knew about computers i i didn't
really know about computers at that time
although you know we'd see him in the
sci-fi movies and tv shows and things
like that right like in buck rogers or
you know star wars so any in any case
um i remember a lunch period where keith
was like i want to show you this thing
so instead of going out and playing at
recess we go into this computer room and
he's typing away
furiously and it was a program that like
made a bunch of stars
you know and we thought that was so cool
right it was kind of mind-blowing
for us and so you know i thought
computers were kind of neat
i didn't know how keith knew about this
or anything like that
and at university lake school which is
where i went for
middle school it was a private middle
school and i've told some stories about
that already
i'll probably tell many more suffice it
to say it was pretty exclusive it had a
massive campus
very small student body a lot of
teachers who probably
should not have been teaching some who
were really great
and it was the kind of place that you
you were either rich or you were smart
and there was
very little overlap between the two i
was there on scholarship that's all my
parents could afford to
send me there as were several other uh
kids who who i became friends with
and uls had not not exactly a computer
lab as such but in at least a few the
rooms they were like banks
of computers and you could sit down and
and work at them
but you actually had to have permission
because they didn't want just anybody
going to town on them and i think if i
remember right you'd have to sign up for
computer time
and some of them had uh the capacity to
use the the tapes some of them didn't
they were different types of commodore
computers i remember there was the pet
and there were some
others as well and i'm not sure
who came up with the idea but university
lake school
had a class that was not just for kids
but for kids and their parents to learn
about
computers i guess they saw it as the
wave of the future which they were
correct about and so
my dad found out about this and
he he said you know it was in the fall
he's like do you want to sign up for
this class and
i said yeah that sounds that sounds cool
and he said well
i'll sign up for it too i want to learn
how to use computers as well it'd be
really handy
so it started in
the spring semester so it meant it
started in the middle of winter
and i don't remember how many sessions
there were maybe it was eight or so
but every saturday for a while we would
you know make the drive in to school and
he and i
would you know park the car and walk to
the the main building
and go in there and there'd be somebody
and i don't know if they actually
worked for uls or if they were somebody
else coming in from the outside
but we would get these these classes and
you know sit down and
tippy type the things into the computer
some of us were very slow typists
my dad actually was a pretty quick
typist and you know we learned
um the basics of what computers were
about and you know
what were the different components and
what could you do and what couldn't you
do
and they there was a book that we
checked out from the library i remember
and it had all these these programs in
it these dos programs
that had you know all these lines and
then it would tell you what the program
did
and i i remember reading through it and
getting kind of excited about it and
like he
my dad and i are looking through it and
being like well that that's kind of a
cool program
maybe we'll have to see if we can
program that in
next time that we get a chance it never
actually
happened like that except for with some
of some of the very short programs
because some of the programs would be
page after page after page
this was a time too by the way when
there were magazines that you could buy
that had all sorts of you know long dos
programs in them as well as
you know all sorts of other computer
related things
that were quite cool so it was like this
this new world that was opening up
and you know i was like uh you know uh
so
1981 i was 10 years old going to be
11 in uh in august
and my dad would have been about 34.
30 35 his birthday was in january
and so it was it was something that we
were doing together and i'll mention
this too as well that
my dad was a very hard worker he
actually was a tax attorney
he had earned a law degree and passed
his cpa
and you know he did a lot of stuff
here in downtown milwaukee actually
we're just a few blocks from where he
used to work
and then he changed jobs so he could be
closer to us
and not be totally gone during tax
season
working as the chief accountant for a
place that
turned out they wanted him to cook the
books whole different story so he ended
up having to leave there but
you know when he had time when he was
when he was you know home on the
weekends or at night and
you know all that he really was engaged
i mean we did all sorts of camping
and we would go we had a boat we'd go
fishing
um you know he took an interest in in
what we were doing
as as did my mom so doing this class
together was not something really that
unusual but it's something that i really
do remember from from our time together
and unfortunately as i think many of you
know my dad died in 1982
um when i was 11 shortly before my
birthday
august 2nd and he was only 36 at the
time
um we were actually supposed to be going
down to
houston texas um he had started working
for
tuschross again and they they wanted him
to open up an office down there so we
were all ready to move
so this is the this would be like the
winter before uh
that year when when he died and and i i
don't think he had you know
any inkling that that was going to to
happen and we certainly
didn't either so this is like something
that that he and i were
doing together to prepare for you know a
future that would include a lot of
computers
and i learned a lot in that class i'm
not sure what he learned because i don't
remember
talking that much about it i think he he
just wanted to actually like
do it with me is something that we would
have fun with and then maybe he'd apply
it
later on and you know i learned the
rudiments
of dos programming i learned a lot of
commands
and how how to understand you know how
how these things
would line up and so it became part of
my repertoire
and you know while i was at uls we would
swap programs here and there people had
written programs
and you know you you would record it on
the first it would you load it up to the
computer then you'd load it on to your
cassette tape that you'd carry around
which you used for all of your your data
and it was all just games
kind of stuff there there was one
program in there that i thought was
really quite cool
which was called eliza and it it was
this is in that book that i was talking
about
it was supposed to replicate a
psychotherapist and it was
you know the very beginning
of a certain kind of a.i you know not a
real ai of course of course but
you see eliza showing up in cyberpunk
novels later on in the 90s like william
gibson
um and other thinkers and i always
wanted to like try to program that in
but it was it was very long
and i didn't have the time to do that so
you know we would putter around with the
computers
they got better unfortunately my dad
like i said died before we could really
reap
many of the benefits of that and but i
but i carried it forward you know
i remember like going over to people's
houses
and you know they would show off the
computer that they had
because that became like a prestige
thing
to have and there were like all sorts of
levels to it you know
if you had a commodore 64 that was
you know kind of a blue blue collar
working class to it's a middle class
kind of thing
the people who had the you know the
really expensive would cost you over a
thousand bucks computers that was you
know the rich people then you had
you know the uh tandy computers in the
middle you had like the zx80 at the very
bottom level
and uh everything in between and you
know dos
wasn't exactly the same in every single
system
but it was it was similar enough that
you'd like go over to somebody's house
and then you start
monkeying around with their computer and
they were usually pretty cool with it
they'd be like wow that kid actually
knows how to program
you know my kids that we bought this for
them and they're not interested in it
all and i
i'd like i was really into adventure
games
and i wanted to create something like
like zorg
you know and so i'd you know we'd be at
somebody's house and i'd be working away
at it
and then of course it was all for naught
because you know
any complex game your your program
you're not going to have the time to to
fully develop it you're not saving it
either so
and then you know by the time that i was
in in high school and we did get a
commodore 64
um we mostly used it for playing games a
bit of word
processing um but i you know i i went
to school um in
in college and my sophomore year
um i got a computer that my friend put
together for me and it was still all
everything was all dos you know um but
things were starting to come out that
were
a lot more complex and so that class
that i took with my dad
um that he wanted to sign up for i think
not
you know maybe because he wanted to do
something with computers but more he
just wanted to hang out with his kid
turned out to be um very useful um
it's not that i do anything with dos
today no nobody really does right but
it proved to be something very helpful
for me
for over a decade and
it was a really nice thing that he did i
remember
you know i have memories of like walking
down the halls with him
and driving out there and driving back
and sitting
by our fireplace in the living room and
like pouring through
this book of programs and talking about
how cool it would be
if we were to program this in so
you know when i sometimes when i see
ancient computers like that ancient
meaning from the 1980s
um those sorts of things come to mind
for me it's
i mean we live in a vastly different
world now where
those computers are basically toys right
not even toys um but that's that's where
we were at that time and for me it's
always connected with this
familial memory and the chance to
reminisce about my my
dad who now has been gone you know
um more than
three quarters of my life
it's a valuable opportunity for me so i
thought i would share that story with
all of you
you